un disparo en el pecho
de 11 años llamó a la policía por
indicaciones de su madre ante la
presencia de un intruso el fin de semana
en su casa de indianola Mississippi una
comunidad de mayoría afroamericana 160
kilómetros de Jackson pero el niño
terminó recibiendo un disparo por parte
del oficial que fue atender los hechos
Él dijo salga con las manos arriba en
ese momento mi hijo salió salir con las
manos en alto y que te disparen no lo
entiendo
el niño estuvo cinco días hospitalizado
por la herida con un pulmón colapsado
laceraciones en el hígado y una costilla
fracturada El oficial
fue retirado de servicio activo mientras
es investigado pero aún goza de sueldo
familiares y vecinos de Adrián
protestaron frente al ayuntamiento de
indianola
pedimos justicia un niño afroamericano
de 11 años estuvo a centímetros de
perder la vida no hizo nada malo hizo
todo bien
qué amenaza suponía él es claramente un
bebé y tú eres un veterano oficial de
policía entrenado que parte de tu
entrenamiento te hace pensar que ese
bebé era una amenaza para ti
la familia ha pedido que se publique el
video de la cámara corporal del oficial
y que este se ha despedido y acusado de
asalto agravado Mississippi se ha visto
sacudido en días recientes por otro caso
de uso de fuerza letal por parte de la
policía en contra de un ciudadano
afroamericano tres ex oficiales tendrán
que enfrentar cargos criminales por la
muerte en custodia de un hombre de 41
años atacado en repetidas ocasiones con
una pistola de aturdimiento durante un
arresto